le tournage de la série le monde de
gabrielle roy se déroule présentement à
saint pierre joly dans le sud est du
manitoba écrite et réalisée par la case
yens renée blanchar leur se veut une
plongée dans l'enfance de l'écrivaine
franco manitobaine gabrielle roy
on est parti de 8,8 texte huit extraits
signifiant de l'oeuvre de gabrielle roy
où il était question d'un moment dont on
peut penser qu'ils ont été des moments
presque des petites épiphanie pour elle
des moments qui l'ont marqué et qui ont
fait cas là on est venu à l'écriture
la comédienne franco manitobaine
marie-eve fontaine campe le rôle de
clémence l'une des soeurs aînées de
gabriel pour elle le scénario témoigne
d'une réelle connaissance de certains
écrits rue deschambault et bonheur
d'occasion
c'est incroyable la recherche toutes les
choses que run est allé chercher elle a
refusé ce pas seulement de rue
deschambault mais audrey crâne et elle a
tout lu l'oeuvre 50 fois elle a mis là
dedans tous cas pouvait évoquer tout ce
qui était simple est important pour
gaston lepage bureau de lyon le père de
gabriel alors que son épouse est
interprété par martin franc/euro de la
grand mare est quant à lui interprété
par francis ruelle c'était l'occasion
pour gaston lepage de replonger dans une
guerre de gabrielle roy
je suis retourné dans l'oeuvre
recommencer à redire
gabrielle roy et puisque rené a en a
fait c'est un petit bijou cdh était déjà
un petit bijou c'est un bijou mais cette
sa mise en mots en situation de ce qu'on
peut voir dans les romains c'est
vraiment formidable
les tournages se poursuivront dans les
prochaines semaines
à winnipeg c'est bien joli et fanny
stand
ici jérimy daniel radio-canada winnipeg